hey what's up guys my name is Ayana and
welcome back to my safe loss class
series so today building off of what we
talked about last time with function
pointers if you haven't seen that video
definitely click up there to check it
out today we're gonna be talking about
talking about Landers and lambdas are
essentially a way to a way for us to
define something that I like to call in
an anonymous function so basically it's
a way for us to create a function
without actually having to physically
create a function just like a quick
disposable function if we want to suck
if we want to demonstrate some kind of
code that needs to be run but we we want
to trade it more like a variable and
less than an actual formal function that
exists as like a symbol in our actual
compiled code if that makes sense and
obviously when we jump into some
examples if that didn't make sense
hopefully they'll clear it up okay so
first of all a lambda right what is it
used for it's one thing to understand
what it is but it's obviously a
completely different thing to understand
how to use it and when to use it and the
answer to that is essentially whenever
you have a function pointer you can use
a lambda in C++ that is how that works
right so a lambda is just a way for us
to literally define a function without
having to define a function so the usage
of al and are therefore is wherever we
would normally set a function pointer to
a function we can set it to a lambda
instead right so really to talk about
why lambdas are useful and where you can
use them you need to understand where
you would use a function pointer and we
definitely did talk about that in the
function pointers video but when we
actually start getting into concrete
examples in C++ and in this series and
especially the game engine series where
we actually build something that's when
you'll really see me use everything that
I described in this series so just keep
that in mind this is more to be treated
as like a reference and like oh I don't
know what this is at all or I don't know
the syntax for this actual thing or how
it works right so let's jump in and
we're going to build off of what we
covered in the function pointers video
to actually demonstrate the usage of a
lambda and the different things that we
can do with it okay so this is the code
that we had from the last video we
basically just built a little for each
function which took in a function
pointer and in fact last video I even
said
that we did user lambda this is a lambda
right over here we did essentially
define our own function in line with the
rest of our code that just printed out
whatever value we needed and this
function pointer essentially defined
what the lambda actually needed to be so
in other words we know that it returns
void and we know that it takes one
parameter which is an integer and that's
why you see this function as you can see
returns nothing it just prints out a
line of text and then we have this
integer value parameter which is defined
because we've said that we need to take
in an integer and in this case the
integer that we pass into this function
ends up being the value that work
currently iterating over right so you
can see that literally this func value
is actually calling this code that we've
defined here in our main function and
that really is the usage of a lambda
lets us do cool things like this one of
the biggest examples I can ever give is
we want to be able to pass in a function
to an API so that at some point in the
future it can call that function for us
because we don't know we can't call the
function now because either it doesn't
have the data it needs or we just don't
want to we want to kind of defer the
calling of a function and if we want to
do something like that then of course we
need to tell it what function to call
when it gets up to the stage if I now
want to call a function and lambdas are
just a really good way of specifying
that function specifying code that you
want to run sometime in the future like
we have here with is for H where we
actually run that code when we're
iterating over the element and when it
becomes time for us to call it with the
specific parameter as we're doing here
so let's dissect the syntax of this
Lambert a little bit I'm actually going
to kind of get rid of this and assign it
to an order variable so order lambda
we'll say equals our lambda and then
we'll pass in the lambda into here all
right cool so first of all we start off
a lambda with these square brackets let
me make some room we start up this
lambda with the square brackets what is
that now I will point out first of all
that you don't really have to take my
word for it or this video for it cuz
sometimes videos are a bit annoying for
things like this you can actually go
over to cpp reference calm as I've got
open over here and there is an
there's a page on lambda expressions you
can see they exist in C++ 11 and they've
actually got the syntax of all the
things you can do and you can see that
what of course the first part is the
captures and of course it describes
everything over here if you've got the
explanation you can see the captures are
a comma separated list of zero or more
captures CPB reference comm is my
favorite superclass reference website
there are many others and you can use
all of them really they're all useful
but this one's actually quite clear and
refer to this often right I'll leave a
link to the lambda page in the
description below but in general if
you're not sure about something like
lambdas or I wonder what goes into that
capture thing or what the possible
values are right if you try to figure
out stuff like that just look it up in
the reference ok so inside here you can
see the captions we have a comma
separated list of zero or more captures
so I'll explain what this is in a minute
but basically you can see that we can
pass in like variables essentially a
would be captured by a copy or a value
and B is captured by reference here we
can pass in this we can pass in just an
ampersand which captures everything by
reference just an equal sign which
captures everything by value or by copy
and then that captures nothing so what
is this whole capturing thing well
consider this as an example what if we
want to put outside variables into the
instructions that are inside our lambda
function what happens then right because
remember what we're doing is we're
constructing a function that will then
get called later
so if we use variables that are outside
of that lambda like for example outside
of this function so maybe I have an aunt
a over here that's equal to 5 what if I
use that here what if the pop will
instead of printing value or something I
want to print a well how is that gonna
work because this is outside and
obviously what I'm doing is calling this
code from over here inside this for each
loop so how does it have access to a
well there's two ways that we can pass
this a variable around and this is the
exact same as if we hadn't made our own
function we can pass it by value or we
can pass it by reference and that is
what that capture group is for write
that first at square brackets that lets
us say how we want to pass vary
apples in now in this case we're not
passing anything in which is why we're
getting an error here because well it's
an enclosing function we can't pass an A
but what we can do is we can either
write equals which means pass everything
in by value or we can write an ampersand
like this which means pass everything in
by reference or we can actually write
individual variables like this so I want
to pass a by value or with an ampersand
a by reference now in this case we
actually get an error when we try and
pass something in well actually if we
capture anything whether it be by value
or by reference we're going to get an
error over here in 4h and this is just
in this specific example because we're
just using a roll function pointer if we
convert this to an STD function like we
will right now so this is gonna be of
course returning for taking in one hint
parameter and we'll call it func I'll
include functional so that we have
access to that then that's gonna go away
okay so what we're doing here is we're
passing everything in by value which
means it's just gonna copy the value and
pass it in but you can also use an
ampersand if you want to capture
something by reference so maybe if it's
like a class or a struct that you don't
want to copy or this lambda is actually
intended to modify the code if you're
not sure or to modify that object or
variable you're not sure what I mean by
passing by reference check out both my
video and functions I think covers a
little bit of that but the references
video and the pointers video is also
related to that all that stuff if we go
back to C++ reference we you can also
say that we have the next step which is
the parameters right those are the
parameters that our function takes in we
have an optional specifier such as
mutable which allows the body to modify
parameters captured by copy that's
another thing that's kind of useful you
can see here that we're copying the a
variable but if we try and assign a to
something like that it's not gonna let
us which is a bit weird because we're
just passing by value and of course if
we were passing something into a normal
function by value of course we can we
can reassign it into whatever we want
and to fix that you basically just out
the word mutable here it's a bit weird
but hey stuff like that you probably
wouldn't even realize exists if you
don't look at things like the reference
and see what's possible because you can
see that over here we have our kind of
parameters and whatever which is one of
them is that that beautiful optional
kind of sequence of specifies Const
expression is another one
as well anyway that's essentially how
long does work it's pretty simple I
don't want to drag this video on because
it makes sense I hope to most people it
is fairly simple the usages of it are
the most important part we're gonna look
at one use for why you might want to use
a lambda in something called
STD find F which is part of the
algorithm pedophile and it's basically
something that we can use to find a
value inside of some kind of iterator so
over here we do have this vector of
values I've included algorithm over here
at the top then I'm going to type in STD
find if so this function is basically
just going to accept some kind of
iterator so we'll give it values begin
and values and so between the beginning
and end of this vector of values that we
have here we can basically say hey
returned for me an iterator that is the
first element that matches whatever kind
of predicate I pass in so in other words
what we can do here is write a function
is going to take in this is a vector of
integers so we'll take an int value and
then it has to return a boolean which
basically says whether or not it
fulfills our condition so we'll say
maybe you value is greater than three or
something like that let's just return
that so return value grid entry so it's
going to look through this vector for
numbers for integers that are larger
than three and return to us an iterator
of that which will essentially be just
the first element so what it should do
hopefully is return five for us so if we
assign this order iterator equals a city
find F and then we'll print out we'll do
reference that iterator and print it up
we should get the value five printing
why because we've specified that we want
a value greater than three using a
lambda and five happens to be the first
number that is greater than three inside
this list of values that we have so if I
just kind of put a breakpoint somewhere
here and run my code you'll see that we
get the value five printing as we
expected and we've managed to do that
fairly easily by just specifying a nice
little quick function that we want this
court this code to call so what this is
going to do is loop through our list
kind of like what I've got here in 4h
and it's as if we just added a little if
value greater than five
and return kind of that value that's
basically what this is doing for us but
we were able to specify this if
statement condition there's bullying by
just using a lambda really quickly like
that anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did you can hit the like
button that's pretty much all there is
to lambdas thank you huge thank you as
always to all of my patreon supporters
you can head on over to patreon my home
4/2 channel and help support all the
videos that I make care of my channel
next time I don't even know what we're
gonna cover next time to be honest
probably we haven't even covered
standard function yet but I feel like
these function pointers I just gonna
drag on for a while and I think you guys
all understand them if you don't
definitely leave a comment below but
anyway I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]